si la crise sanitaire a donné du fil à
retordre à l'union européenne
la crise économique risque de l'être
tout autant depuis plusieurs semaines
les états membres négocient pour lancer
un plan de relance problème des
divergences sont nombreuses et chacun
veut des conditions avantageuses
au point que le président du conseil
européen à déclencher la sonnette
d'alarmé en priant les pays de trouver
un terrain d'entente
je sais que pendant le sommet nous
aurons des décisions difficiles à
prendre mais je compte sur le courage
politique
je pense qu'il est maintenant temps
d'agir il est maintenant temps de dc 10
et j'espère qu'il sera possible pour
tout le monde autour de la table de
faire un pas en direction d'une décision
c'est en fait de ces jeunes un accord
avait pourtant été trouvé le 18 mai
dernier entre la france et l'allemagne
l'europe s'était félicité mais des
contestataires se sont vite révélées
pays bas autriche danemark et suède ont
décidé de former un front de
contestation appelé les quatre frugaux
afin de remettre en cause le budget a
admis pour les pays les plus touchés par
le cos vide 19 pour régler ce conflit
le conseil européen a décidé d'ajuster
le budget pour plaire au plus grand
nombre un montant de 1000 74 milliards
d'euros sur sept ans a été prévu au lieu
des 1100 milliards proposé en mai
dernier
présidente de l'union européenne angéla
merkel soit un accord rapide
la plus grande priorité de la présidence
allemande du conseil de l'union
européenne et que l'europe sorte unis et
fortifié de la crise mais nous ne
voulons pas seulement stabilisé l'europe
à court terme cela ne serait pas assez
nous voulons également une europe qui
donne de l'espoir
notre objectif commun est de parvenir à
un accord le plus rapidement possible
car l'ampleur du marasme économique nous
rappelle qu'il faut se dépêcher
nous ne devons pas perdre de temps les
plus pauvres paient les pots cassés
j'espère vivement que nous pourrons
trouver un accord cet été pour éviter
une complication de la situation
l'union européenne va devoir mettre de
côté ses divergences et trouver vite un
accord
une nouvelle chance lui sera donnée les
17 et 18 juillet lors du prochain sommet
réunissant les dirigeants des états
membres pour leur première rencontre
physique
depuis le début de la crise sanitaire